la plus grosse
280 euros tu vas payer 70 euros de
démarche
240 euros de transport avant mise en
bière
tu vas tu vas l'avoir gratos aussi donc
ça c'est
tarif extravagant pratique douteuse loi
du silence le secteur des pompes
funèbres ne s'est toujours pas
débarrassé de cette mauvaise image
la mort un sujet intime est à bout dans
notre société et qui permet à certains
professionnels d'abuser des familles
endeuillées
au-delà de la dérive des prix nous avons
découvert des pratiques scandaleuses et
indignes connues par beaucoup de
professionnels
il y en a qui font ça ta mère tu voudras
qu'on la mette comme ça dans le sapin
[Applaudissements]
on nous demandait de fouiller essayer de
récupérer les livres de famille fallait
absolument récupérer des documents pour
pouvoir ramener ça à notre patron face
au scandale certains n'hésitent pas à
briser la loi du silence ou à se battre
pour que les défunts et leurs familles
soient respectées
si je le fais aujourd'hui c'est pour les
familles c'est pour les défunts un
combat contre ceux qui dépassent les
limites de la morale
pendant plusieurs mois un de nos
journalistes a infiltré ce milieu secret
qui préfère toujours rester dans l'ombre
le malheur des uns fait souvent le
bonheur des autres une expression
particulièrement adaptée aux pompes
funèbres
un secteur qui pèse près de 2 milliards
d'euros par an et la facture n'a cessé
d'augmenter pour les familles
endeuillées plus 35% en 10 ans
[Musique]
une dérive des prix incontrôlées et un
secteur qui souffre encore d'une
mauvaise réputation malversation
financière à faire sordide la presse
fait régulièrement les gros titres sur
des cas de pratiques douteuses
des fraudes des escroqueries alors que
les familles qui viennent de perdre un
proche sont particulièrement vulnérables
je cherche à me faire embaucher dans ce
milieu très fermé pour voir si cette
réputation sulfureuse est exacte je
postule pour un poste de commercial je
rédige une lettre de motivation un CV
puis je passe des dizaines de coups de
fil un peu partout en France les
premiers résultats sont plutôt décevants
[Musique]
je voulais savoir si vous aviez besoin
de personnes
vous cherchez personne d'accord je
voulais savoir si vous aviez des postes
dans votre société
il n'y a pas de
[Musique]
ce qu'il faut d'accord
pas d'embauche de commercial visiblement
ce secteur a un petit problème et pour
cause le nombre de décès a tendance à
diminuer on a compté 531 000 morts en
2011 c'est près de 8900 en moins par
rapport à 2017 grâce au progrès de la
médecine les Français vivent plus vieux
la courbe des décès stable aujourd'hui
devrait décoller d'ici les années 2030
avec la disparition de la génération du
baby-boom on comptera alors plus de 700
000 morts par an le marché est promis un
bel avenir
[Musique]
en attendant le secteur connaît
aujourd'hui la crise et les postes sont
rares pour multiplier les chances avec
d'autres journalistes nous nous rendons
dans différentes sociétés pour tenter
cette fois-ci de nous faire embaucher en
tant que porteur de cercueil
nous partons avec CV lettre de
motivation
et de la motivation nous allons en avoir
besoin
je vais voir ce que je suis à la
recherche d'un travail
et je voulais savoir si vous cherchiez
des personnels en ce moment vous avez
déjà fait les morts
non en fait
avant je sais pas du tout dans ce
secteur là je travaillais
quand je fais des petits boulots j'étais
serveur dans la manutention tout ça et
facile pour passer pas difficile mais
des fois c'est très difficile quand vous
avez quelqu'un ici ramassé du 5e étage
vous la ressortez le métro
dans le lit bien entendu c'est surtout
des
trucs qui sont difficiles
c'était un
métier certes difficile mais quand même
qui
tu vois qui permettait de bien gagner sa
vie
il vous faut extrêmement bien sûr 2000
euros
entre 1500 et 1200 euros entre 1200
d'accord
S
[Applaudissements]
faire des trous dans le cimetière
parce que
[Musique]
moi
l'exploitation de l'homme par l'homme me
voilà prévenu
après avoir visité une trentaine de
pompes funèbres toujours pas d'embauche
lors d'un entretien nous allons
découvrir une autre pratique très
répandue dans le secteur des pompes
funèbres celle de la sous-traitance
parce que je suis à la recherche d'un
emploi
et je voulais savoir
avec eux
quand on est dans la merde des fois il
faut se faire aider c'est embauche pas
mal en ce moment c'est comme tout en ce
moment il y a pas beaucoup de boulot
parce que le temps est très clément et
en ce moment vous avez de l'activité je
souhaiterais ce sont mes fournisseurs
qui me fournissaient par terre mais vous
êtes l'activité en ce moment
mais c'est encore un secteur qui
a du pour les fournisseurs ils sont dans
les techniques parce nous on est il y a
beaucoup de concurrence donc celui qui
fournit des entreprises à du boulot
parce que marcher sadomisé donc il y a
beaucoup d'entreprises qui amènent
lui il a toujours le même boulot c'est
nous qui souffrons parce qu'on est en
concurrence souvent c'est pas pareil
mais vous êtes grand vous êtes costaud
et je peux très bien avoir besoin de le
d'un collaborateurs
il y a pas de boulot on achète pas c'est
midi qui s'amusent avec les 35 heures
c'est pas moi d'accord voilà si j'y vais
ils peuvent me rappeler au bouton
bon courage Bonne chance ce sont donc
les prestataires qui embauchent le plus
dans le secteur des pompes funèbres
c'est d'ailleurs dans ce type de société
que j'obtiens mon premier poste je serai
mise à laisser pendant 15 jours en tant
que porteur de cercueil pour ce travail
manuel mais hautement solennel le
costume est de rigueur
petite particularité le mien est équipé
de caméras cachées
contrairement aux autres métiers du
funéraire il n'est pas nécessaire
d'effectuer une formation pour être
porteur premier jour rendez-vous à 7h45
dans des locaux situés au sud de Paris
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
l'accueil de la part de mes collègues
est assez chaleureux
après les présentations petit briefing
avec le responsable du planning qui doit
m'expliquer quel sera mon rôle pour les
prochains jours
[Applaudissements]
bien c'est-à-dire prendre le corps sur
un plateau de mettre dans le cercueil et
puis après à l'église dans les églises
il y a des trucs à mémorisés
et ensuite c'est comment l'inhumation
après il y a certaines choses il y a
certaines choses c'est psychologique
c'est voilà où tu ne supportes qui
supporte pas
de psychologique tu peux le passer si tu
supportes pas je veux pas insister il
faut le dire
[Musique]
mon travail consiste donc à porter le
cercueil tout au long d'une journée
d'enterrement
mes collègues m'expliquent brièvement la
meilleure technique pour le charger sur
mes épaules on fait une simulation pour
moi
et tu vas t'aider avec les la main
gauche pour en dessous
il est sur quelque chose c'est un peu de
cette hauteur là quoi
donc là voilà donc
la personne va annoncer Messi on va
partir à la marche du pied gauche
c'est la main gauche dans le dos voilà
avec le poids du corps du mort en plus
il faut compter entre 120 et 150 kg de
charges sinon déjà enfin j'imagine avec
quelqu'un
[Musique]
les premiers rudiments du métier
assimilés je pars pour mon premier
enterrement avec le maître de cérémonie
cela fait une dizaine d'années qu'il est
dans la profession et tout de suite il
me met en garde
comme le domaine de la fonctionnelle
c'est comme quelque chose de très fermé
ça agit un peu comme une communauté
c'est-à-dire tout se sait et puis ça
parle tu sais il y a plein de choses qui
circulent
faire attention quand on ouvre la bouche
tu verras des trucs soit qui monte
impressionner ou au contraire qui est
contre d'écouter par rapport à quoi je
sais pas par exemple tu vois tu fais des
tu fais une mise en bière donc tu places
le corps dans l'intercueil et puis il y
a une autre boîte de pompes funèbres qui
est à côté de toi toi tu vas prendre le
corps avec soin et puis tu vas essayer
de le déposer délicatement tu verras la
boîte de pompe à côté bon jeter le corps
comme si c'était un sac à patate
[Musique]
c'est ta mère que ta mère qui voudra
qu'on la mette comme ça dans le sale
tête
c'est souvent les mêmes ou c'est
sûrement
direction une morgue de la région
parisienne là où les corps sont
conservés dans des caissons réfrigérées
première mise en bière premier contact
avec un mort
visiblement je suis bien tombé ici tout
est fait dans le respect des défunts
[Musique]
après un dernier adieu de la famille
fermeture du cercueil avec la présence
obligatoire d'un policier qui doit poser
un CD cette formalité accomplie on peut
emmener le corps pour la cérémonie
religieuse au crématorium ou directement
au cimetière nous reprenons la route au
fil de la discussion le maître de
cérémonie devient plus bavard notamment
en ce qui concerne le prix des obsèques
[Musique]
c'est libre c'est complètement libre et
tu verras des aberrations au niveau des
au niveau des tarifs qui sont un peu
absolument mais rocambolesque les gens
sont ignorants pour la plupart de ce qui
se passe dans la pompe funèbre tu leur
présentes un devis bon ils savent à peu
près à quoi ça correspond mais bon après
tu peux leur laisser tu peux leur
glisser plein de trucs parce que Ben en
effet à ce moment-là après moi je en
tout ce qui est finance j'observe
beaucoup mais enfin voilà je m'en occupe
pas il y a beaucoup de personnes qui
font du chiffre parce qu'il y a de
l'argent à faire dans la pompe funèbre
donc il y a beaucoup de
il y a beaucoup d'arnaques pour trop peu
de personnes voilà qui font vraiment du
boulot le boulot comme comme il faut
quoi dans le secteur il y a peut-être 9
qui font bien pour un qui est croque non
c'est un petit peu j'ai l'impression que
c'était vrai que c'est peut-être quatre
qui font bien et
c'est ce qui abuse quand même
question prix des obsèques ce serait
donc le grand flou pour le client
je vais tenter de me le faire confirmer
et pour cela je n'ai pas besoin d'aller
très loin un jour où je termine plutôt
j'ai l'occasion de rencontrer le
commercial de la société cette
entreprise de prestation funéraire a
également une activité de pompes
funèbres avec une boutique où elle
reçoit des familles endeuillées je
sympathise avec ce vendeur et lui
demande des conseils
[Musique]
faut se mettre dans le rythme et tout
c'est pas forcément évident mais ça va
ouais ça plaît écoute moi ce qui
m'intéresse plus c'est tout ce qui est
plutôt conseillé funéraire d'en parler
avec toi
première chose à faire c'est quand être
une famille
[Musique]
si tu arrives à garder ça c'est sûr que
la famille va
pourquoi c'est important de garder le
monde et tu arrives à garder le livret
de famille et la carte d'identité
tu puisses donner l'impression d'être
sûr de toi jamais douter ça me fait du
style le client
tu leur réponds les tensions de toi tu
sais que tu es en train de mentir comme
quoi comme question
[Musique]
plus vite même si c'est pas forcément
vrai
mais le truc c'est est-ce que il y a pas
une limite parce que on est quand même
sur la mort de personne ou ça reste un
business et donc il faut il faut des
chiffres et
par contre sortir rassurant quand tu es
libre on peut faire une simulation ah
ouais c'est pas mal ça serait cool que
ça fasse vendredi après-midi salut salut
merci pour les conseils salut au revoir
[Musique]
en attendant il me faut retourner à mon
métier de porteur celui pour lequel j'ai
été embauché
les enterrements s'enchaînent les
journées sont longues entre les mises en
bière dans les funérarium les cérémonies
à l'église et le cimetière avec en
moyenne deux enterrements par jour plus
que le poids des cercueils se sont
surtout les longues heures d'attentes
qui use et fatiguent le quotidien des
porteurs c'est généralement 15 minutes
d'action pour une heure d'attente en
extérieur était comme hiver le tout pour
un salaire autour de 1400 euros brut
[Musique]
quelques jours plus tard j'ai enfin un
temps libre pour pouvoir retrouver le
commercial de la société comme prévu
nous faisons ensemble une simulation de
devis en guise d'exemple il s'appuie sur
le dossier d'une famille reçu quelques
semaines plus tôt au magasin
là
il doit être resté TVA payé certes payé
tout payé de notre 2000 euros
mais ce qui est pas forcément énorme
quand il faut payer plein de mecs
derrière non si tu les as payé ah tu les
as payé d'accord
pour l'entreprise sur une facture à 6600
euros
alors comment fait-il pour gonfler le
devis artificiellement et arriver à ce
résultat
toilettes et habillage c'est à dire que
ça je le fais facturer mais ça me coûte
pas grand-chose
280 euros tu vas payer 70 euros de
démarche
240 euros de transport avant de mise en
bière négocie bien tu vas tu vas l'avoir
gratos aussi donc pour ça c'est
pareil livraison cercueil
c'est que du gras
ça ça
c'est la même chose c'est quelque chose
qui va te coûter grosso modo on va dire
50 euros et que là moi j'ai facturé 45
33 40 11 grosso modo là tu vas payer 50
euros et tu auras rentré de ce groupe
après quand tu reçois les chalets il
faut que tu marques des trucs offerts ça
fait super important aussi
d'avoir des cadeaux ils m'offre un truc
à 65 euros ils doivent un truc
à 100 euros sauf que c'est des choses
qui de toute façon sont compris ou ou
vous acceptez de gagner moins
moins cher j'ai remonté mon truc 320 à
330 euros mais je vais vous faire la
semaine d'accord si c'est une personne
tu sens qu'elle peut payer plus tu ça tu
l'ouvres pas tout court ou tu vois
toujours un petit peu ça fera toujours
même si elle est pognon
il y a un porteur de côté là il est pas
marqué
regarde le porteur
110 € en plus
commercial comptabilise donc un
corbillard ainsi que quatre porteurs ce
connaissait pas le client c'est que le
prix du corbillard comprend déjà un
chauffeur qui porte aussi le cercueil
logiquement la facture ne devrait
comporter que trois porteurs alors qu'il
y en a quatre de facturer une petite
arnaque bien connue dans le milieu
et en gros en moyenne entièrement
classique il est à combien en général tu
vas tourner sur un billet de 3005 4000
euros mais quand tu as une famille
d'accord ça c'est une connaissance ils
sont venus
demain tu rentres tu viens me voir je
vais me monter le matin j'ai besoin de
7000 €
.
si tu montes ton entreprise tu sais très
bien
l'argent rentre il faut que quand on
manquait t'appelle tu saches te répondre
mais est-ce qu'il y a est-ce que ça va
jusqu'à mentir parfois aux gens ou
ah oui
que tu es là pour faire rentrer de
l'argent et faire votre largement à la
boîte et le clip
à se faire il y a visiblement dans ce
secteur très concurrentiel certains
n'ont pas de scrupules et tous les coups
sont permis
des
ok ok
cette leçon de vente accélérée me
confirme que chaque société de pompes
funèbres peut gonfler la facture à sa
guise et effectuer un devis à la tête du
client alors comment les familles
font-elles pour s'en sortir dans cette
jungle de prix
nous décidons de comparer les écarts de
tarifs dans le secteur en faisant un
testing nous faisons appel à une actrice
qui sera notre complice elle va faire ce
qu'aucune famille endeuillée n'a le
temps ou le courage de faire
demander à plusieurs pompes funèbres un
devis
elle va prétendre avoir perdu son mari
dans la nuit d'une crise cardiaque
équipée d'une caméra cachée elle se rend
donc dans trois pompes funèbres situées
dans la même rue d'une ville de la
région parisienne
pour ce testing afin de pouvoir comparer
les prix notre complice demandera les
mêmes prestations les obsèques
classiques un cercueil enchaîne massif
et un caveau de place
[Musique]
première pompe funèbre
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mon fils ne peut pas arriver selon deux
ou trois jours alors
donc moi je vais pas rater une brosse à
ses obsèques je vais m'occuper de toutes
les démarches pour organiser
le début jusqu'à la fin qu'est-ce que
vous voulez comme type de structure il y
a deux choses l'organisation est très
professionnelle il faut dire que nous
sommes dans une boutique appartenant à
un grand groupe l'ensemble des
prestations nous est présenté inhumation
dans un caveau ou en pleine terre
organisation de la cérémonie type de
granit pour la pierre tombale tout y
passe une petite salle et même aménagée
pour présenter les différents modèles de
cercueil
[Musique]
en tout l'échange dure près de 40
minutes c'est l'heure de présenter le
devis
[Musique]
bilan de cette première société un devis
de 72008 euros une note assez salée mais
rien à dire sur le service à aucun
moment notre complice ne s'est senti
poussé à dépenser plus que nécessaire
[Musique]
direction ensuite une seconde pompe
funèbre quelques mètres plus loin dans
la rue
l'entretien se déroule encore
normalement il reste quand même quelques
points éclaircir au moment du devis car
tous les frais ne sont pas très clairs
préparation du cercueil
c'est à dire c'est quoi ça alors comme
vous avez pu voir
sont séparés il faut tout rassembler il
faut faire la plaque d'identité tout ça
c'est nous qui faisons en fait
directement
152 euros ok 152 euros pour préparer le
cercueil
pour avoir fait des mises en bière
pendant 15 jours je sais que ce prix est
excessif car il s'agit de placer le
capiton et de la ouate à l'intérieur du
cercueil une opération qui se fait en
quelques minutes mais ça le client ne le
sait pas ces frais ne sont pas forcément
justifiés mais ils permettent à notre
commerçante de gonfler son devis
donc là on arrive à un total de 6295
euros le creusant avec le travail
je vous remercie beaucoup
au revoir
la troisième pompe funèbre à l'autre
bout de la rue est une petite société
indépendante
de la boutique se montre très
entreprenantes la mairie la police
le transfert vous n'avez aucune démarche
à faire nous on s'occupe de tout
d'accord
vous avez une certification
vous avez votre livret de famille ah non
j'ai rien avec moi vous n'avez rien
de famille et scientifique
je dois aller comme je l'avais déjà
appris lors de mon infiltration ici
aussi l'objectif est de mettre la main
sur le livret de famille pour s'assurer
de conclure l'affaire et tout est bon
pour accélérer les choses
donc si vous voulez moi je peux
commencer les démarches au niveau de la
mairie
vous êtes gentil est-ce qu'il va me
rassurer c'est d'avoir mon fils au
téléphone je vais expliquer tout ça et
vous voulez qu'on appelle d'ici votre
fils on ne peut pas le joindre au
travail
alors si vous faites un cadeau de glace
ça fait 5 minutes 104
le transfert le funérarium c'est pareil
jusqu'au dernier moment le responsable
fera le maximum pour amener notre
complice à son domicile pour récupérer
ses papiers
d'accord si vous le permettez je passe
demain matin chez vous pour récupérer le
livret de famille quelle certitude
au revoir cette société malgré son
assistance et celle qui pratique les
tarifs les moins chers
bilan de ce testing on constate un écart
de plus de 2000 euros pour des
prestations équivalentes une différence
flagrante que l'on retrouve à tous les
postes de dépenses par exemple pour le
maître de cérémonie les prix vont de 69
euros et grimpent jusqu'à 220 euros soit
3 fois plus cher rien d'illégal les prix
sont libres dans le secteur mais ces
deux vies étaient-ils suffisamment
claires dans leur présentation
des prix dans les pompes funèbres plus
de 35% en 10 ans à pousser le
législateur à intervenir pour éviter les
abus depuis le 1er janvier 2011 les
pompes funèbres doivent établir un devis
type pour aider les familles à comparer
les prix et les services pour plus de
clarté ce devis doit comporter 8 parties
correspondant aux prestations
obligatoires et optionnelles d'un
enterrement
nous demandons l'expertise à
l'association de consommateurs UFC Que
Choisir qui est réalisé en 2011 une
grande enquête dans plus de 1000 pompes
funèbres à travers la France et récolter
près de 820 de vie
selon eux la majorité des sociétés ne
respectent pas cette nouvelle
législation qu'en est-il des trois devis
de notre testing donc ça c'est le
premier devis
il nous en manque à tout le transport
après les ambiaires je l'ai pas
pourtant il y a forcément un transport
on a le transport avant mes ambiaires
est obligé comme de pas mal s'interroger
alors qu'elle connaît comme très très
bien maintenant le marché et les devis
des pompes funèbres parce qu'elle en a
regardé et reçu des dizaines et des
dizaines et il y a là à la lecture de ce
devis il y a des prestations qu'elle
cherche et qu'elle trouve pas
spontanément le deuxième de ville a
encore et bien il est
on n'a pas toutes
formes non plus parce qu'on a pas toutes
les catégories prestations et enfin le
dernier alors là on est carrément dans
le grand n'importe quoi ça ça devait
être des modèles de devis qui doivent
dater des années 80 quand tu regardes
c'est hyper compliqué de s'y retrouver
on voit même pas où est le prix le bal
alors celui-là il est carrément
non conforme donc le verdict 1 2 et le
troisième le troisième le troisième il
est là le troisième les trois devis que
nous a apporté et bien ils ne sont pas
conformes et il y en a deux qui se
rapprochent un peu de la réglementation
au cours de mon infiltration j'ai donc
découvert comment les devis étaient
artificiellement gonflés mais les
prestations sont-elles bien faites
pendant les longs trajets en camion mon
collègue continue à me décrire les
dessous du métier mettre de cérémonie il
est aussi thanatopracteur c'est-à-dire
qu'il effectue des soins de conservation
ce qui consiste à remplacer le sang des
défunts par une solution à base de
formol
des soins qui eux aussi peuvent être
source de valses de prix par exemple en
facture à un client un soin de
conservation 300 euros 300 à 350 euros
ce qui correspond à peu près du marché
peut-être à des gens les futurs ça ça
peut même pas si tu veux une
illustration t'as pas très longtemps
qu'on a fait d'arriver de corps donc le
gars arrive et c'était le patron de la
boîte en question
[Musique]
lui aussi donc bah voilà on discute et
faut savoir qu'un soin de conservation
ça dure entre 1h15 et 1h30 et le gars il
me fait ouais ben moi je te montre par
jour que ce soit par jour c'est bon et
le mec il me fait ouais mais bon des
fois voilà
25 minutes 30 minutes on injecte vite
fait et puis voilà c'est bon
oui oui il y a pas besoin de 3h un petit
peu et puis c'est terminé c'est un soin
que vous faites la monsieur c'était trop
dans le secteur des pompes funèbres
c'est souvent l'omerta
pour éviter de salir toute une
profession on préfère taire un scandale
plutôt que de le dénoncer mais en
interne les langues se délient je vais
finir par connaître le nom d'une société
souvent montrée du doigt pour ces
mauvaises pratiques j'apprends qu'un de
ces ex salariés que nous appellerons
Tony accepterait de parler à un
journaliste je le contacte et lui
explique que je mène une enquête sur le
sujet il accepte de me rencontrer
discrètement il vient juste de quitter
le milieu du funéraire dégoûté par les
pratiques qu'il a découvertes dans la
société où il a travaillé pendant trois
ans
je commençais à
je me sentais plus bien je me suis fait
j'avais plus de j'ai l'impression de
plus respecter les défunts
ça me faisait mal au cœur
et donc j'ai commencé à chercher autre
chose mais j'ai dit que je garderai des
preuves de ce que j'ai vu moi j'ai
aucune vengeance personnelle si je le
fais aujourd'hui c'est pour les familles
c'est pour les défunts
et ces fameuses preuves ce sont des
photos et des films d'un soin de
conservation que Tony a discrètement
tourné avec son téléphone portable des
images compromettantes pour la société
en théorie les soins se font soit au
domicile du défunt à l'hôpital ou au
funérarium une déclaration est ensuite
déposée à l'hôpital ainsi qu'à la
préfecture pour indiquer où les soins
ont été effectués Tony a vu que ce
n'était pas toujours le cas
ça commençait en fait de aller chercher
une dame qui était dessiné un hôpital
donc on est parti la chercher on l'a
ramené donc le responsable nous a dit de
la ramener au bureau qu'on ferait le
soin de conservation au bureau donc on a
dit à l'hôpital qui avait pas de sur le
conservation
pour ton déclaration sur un qui a été
faite au niveau de la préfecture de
police
le patron de la société aurait donc
menti à l'hôpital pour gagner du temps
et économiser la location d'une salle de
soins il aurait également fait une
fausse déclaration à la préfecture en
prétendant avoir fait des soins à
l'hôpital mais il y a plus grave
c'est un soin qui est fait ou ça dans le
garage de la société
voilà donc là on a bien la personne qui
a mangé donc qui est en train de subir
le son de conservation et là bas qui est
en train de faire son boulot qui est
la vidéo c'est la personne qui est en
train de
faire le son de conservation mais on a
donc le camion avec le la partie
frigorifié
là on a tout le garage donc là on voit
bien que voilà c'est une toiture c'est
vraiment un truc qui est pas
au niveau hygiène qui est mort on a
toute la vaisselle ou des chauffeurs
et quand on va un peu plus loin qu'on va
voir un peu plus loin voilà alors quand
on a les toilettes les toilettes du
personnel
même pas de mettre mais moi j'étais
entre la personne et les toilettes qui a
vraiment pas beaucoup de place pas
d'hygiène irrespectueux pour le défunt
enfin toujours dans un souci d'économie
de corps ont été transportés dans le
même camion alors qu'il n'y avait qu'un
seul caisson réfrigéré pour deux
cercueils on a mis les deux dans le
camion donc le cercueil youtube avec
toutes les fleurs autour pour camoufler
et la dame à l'intérieur et il y a pas
de coupure entre nous et le caisson donc
la personne elle était quasiment à notre
contact les deux familles ont payé plein
pot alors que ils ont utilisé qu'un seul
camion et qu'un seul chauffeur
résultat un des deux corps a fait plus
de 700 km heure d'un caisson réfrigéré
avec un collègue journaliste nous
décidons d’aller voir cette entreprise
pour y rencontrer son responsable une
entreprise qui n'aime pas les curieux et
qui sait que Tony son ancienne employé
par la légende dans ce petit milieu tout
se sait très vite
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
si les employés sont bien là le patron
semble avoir disparu merci au revoir
malgré nos nombreux messages pendant
plusieurs semaines il ne rappellera
jamais
Tony a alerté l'agence régionale de
santé et la sous-préfecture en leur
écrivant une lettre nous contactons les
responsables de ces institutions pour en
savoir plus
la préfecture reçoit et donc il y a déjà
eu sur cette société plusieurs
inspections de réaliser et dans une
société
première rapport sur des
directivités de soi s'adapter 2007 il y
a eu la nouvelle signalement en 2010 ça
fait plusieurs années qu'on suit le
dossier de près dans les années
précédentes en gros il y avait pas eu de
preuve suffisante pour
nous
il y avait pas eu de dysfonctionnement
majeurs de repérer ces gens de choses
qui est Monique et pas évident quoi
prendre en flagrant délit un acte
ou éventuellement il y a un
fonctionnement et encore cette société
est donc sous étroite surveillance en
attendant faut être prise en flagrant
délit elle continue d'exercer son
activité
au cours de notre infiltration nous
avons appris qu'une autre société de
pompes funèbres serait allée encore plus
loin dans des actes de malversation et
qu'elle fait l'objet d'une enquête de
police approfondie différents témoins
ont ainsi déclaré à la police des choses
à peine croyable des clients auraient
été menacés des employés auraient été
obligés par leur patron à fouiller chez
les familles pour récupérer les papiers
il y aurait donc de nombreuses pratiques
illégales je vais partir à la rencontre
de ces témoins l'enquête est sensible
car elle impliquerait des services de
police la société est soupçonnée d'avoir
corrompu des fonctionnaires afin
d'obtenir des réquisitions de police
ces réquisitions des pompes funèbres
interviennent à la suite de mort non
naturels accident suicide meurtre pour
transporter les corps vers une morgue
une activité extrêmement rentable pour
les pompes funèbres nous avons rencontré
une famille qui a perdu sa fille et qui
accepte de parler
c'est ignoble de profiter de la peine
des gens pour les escroquer c'est je
trouve ça ignoble c'est scandaleux
dans des conditions dramatiques c'est
des bêtes ces gens là
la société incriminée a tout d'abord
transporté le corps de leur fille dans
un funérarium après de 30 km de distance
l'objectif aurait été de le rapprocher
de ses locaux pour s'assurer que la
famille passe forcément par eux pour
gérer les obsèques
on a su que le corps se trouvait qu'il
nous a paru bizarre pourquoi
alors que il y a des funérariums bien
plus près à partir du moment où il y a
quelqu'un qui a été comme c'est le cas
de ma fille découvert chez elle
automatiquement c'est sale le
l'administration qui paye le transport
pour aller au funérarium donc la société
se faisait payer deux fois je faisais
payer deux fois une fois par
l'administration une fois par nous nous
avons d'abord reçu la facture non pas
réagit pas payer bien entendu et
derrière il y a une relance et derrière
cette relance il y a eu une société de
recouvrement qui nous demandait des
frais supplémentaires et là encore nous
avons refusé de payer parce que c'était
de l'arnaque c'était du vol ni plus ni
moins
outre ces troublant pour cette famille
ce ne serait pas un hasard si la police
a appelé cette société en particulier il
y a une collusion avec avec le
commissariat car moi j'ai quand même
aimé demandé au commissariat pourquoi et
de quel droit le transporteur avait
décidé de l'emmener et ils m'ont répondu
derrière que c'était pas eux les
décisionnaires ce qui est totalement
faux car dans la réquisition à personne
c'est l'officier de police qui a signé
et demandait le transport donc le
commissariat est dans le coup
certains commissariats de police
seraient donc de mèches avec cette pompe
funèbre pour les appeler en priorité sur
les réquisitions un ex salarié de la
société confirme ses échanges de bons
procédés
[Musique]
pour qu'on puisse récupérer un maximum
de corps leur requise pour pouvoir
justement récupérer ensuite les convois
pour que la police puisse nous appeler
en priorité en
auto patron leur faisait des petits
cadeaux donc il y avait une distribution
d'objets publicitaires pour les
commissariats il y avait des cadeaux des
enveloppes des caisses de vin des du
champagne surtout aux EPJ qui qui
s'occupent des affaires mortuaires voilà
ces personnes nous disaient bien
remercié notre patron
ça concernait pas mal de commissariats
et le patron ne se serait pas arrêté là
poussant même ses employés à dérober des
documents
en nous demandait de fouiller essayer de
récupérer des documents pour avoir les
renseignements bancaires les livrets de
famille fallait absolument récupérer des
documents pour pouvoir ramener ça à
notre patron ça nous faisait un petit
plus puisqu'à chaque fois qu'on
récupérait un document ça nous faisait
une demi prime en plus soit 23 euros
lorsque l'on suivait pas la consigne la
punition c'était de ne plus faire de
requises pendant un certain temps alors
bien sûr c'était quand même un gros
problème parce que le salaire est
diminué sérieusement quoi j'ai quitté
cette société il y a quelques temps déjà
et j'ai le contact avec mes anciens
collègues et cette pratique continue
toujours
les propos de cet employé sont confirmés
par cette famille qui a eu toutes les
peines pour récupérer ses papiers
d'accord
et pour faire les obsèques nous au
départ déjà on voulait pas passer par
eux donc le lendemain vous vous y êtes
allé vous avez pu récupérer vos papiers
c'est mis un petit peu en colère mon
frère a voulu lui arracher le papier
d'une main mais bon voilà moi le
lendemain j'ai reçu des menaces par
téléphone je suis
on va s'occuper de vous dans les jours
qui viennent donc comme on a eu très
peur on est quand même aller déposer une
main courante au commissariat oui une
enquête a été ouverte depuis plus de
trois ans en attendant cette société
continue elle aussi d'exercer son
activité
pour continuer mon infiltration je
parviens à obtenir un stage dans une
nouvelle société je vais découvrir que
les pompes funèbres ne sont pas les
seuls responsables des abus dans les
familles sont victimes
nous sommes appelés par une maison de
retraite pour transporter le corps d'une
personne décédée vers un funérarium
[Applaudissements]
selon la loi c'est à la maison de
retraite de payer ce transport ainsi que
les trois premiers jours de funérarium
une réglementation très claire définie
dans le Code général des collectivités
territoriales
une obligation rarement respectée par
les maisons de retraite qui font souvent
payer ses charges aux familles mon
collègue chargé de faire ce transport a
donc régulièrement des problèmes pour
faire signer les papiers de prise en
charge la discussion s'engage dans
l'ascenseur avec une des responsables de
la maison de retraite
le transport de quoi moi je mets du
réserve c'est que les frais ne sont pas
imputables parce que normalement
c'est l'article 22379
de régler c'est le signer la demande
d'admission à votre nom et la demande de
transport parce que c'est vous qui le
demandez vous ne pouvez pas garder le
corps c'est ça
peut servir en fait
c'est que c'est toutes les mises en fait
elle est finie comme ça
donc c'est un peu gênant quoi
[Applaudissements]
cette responsable de l'établissement
refuse donc de payer ce transport et
nous avons une autre mauvaise surprise
en entrant dans la chambre le corps de
la défunte installé sur une table
réfrigérée afin d'assurer une meilleure
conservation et complètement congelé
[Applaudissements]
ça change pas le problème c'est la loi
c'est la bonne
bonjour une autre responsable de la
maison de retraite nous rejoint dans la
chambre il y a une loi elle est bien
précise à partir du moment où
on fait pas payer le premier des trois
premier pardon et le transport
il y a pas que ça dans le final
bon là de l'occupation là de toute façon
ils ont bien dit vous voulez pas payer
de toute façon ça vous embête je vais
quand même faire le transport puisque
ils ont déjà signé des pâtes chez moi
donc moi ça m'empêche pas de faire le
transport mais bon j'ai pris un acte que
Ben après faites ce que vous voulez avec
votre avocat tout ça j'ai pris hâte que
vous n'avez pas vous me dites vous
n'avez pas à payer tout ça d'accord
et effectivement
[Musique]
c'est qui qui est une et elle
nous envoie un truc avec la facture des
trucs alors et donc on avait pas la loi
ni rien donc elle a tout balancé chez
les avocats et
là on a découvert la loi effectivement
j'apprends ainsi que ce type
d'établissement préfère transférer les
mourants dans un hôpital afin de s'en
débarrasser avant leur décès pour éviter
de payer les frais de transport vers un
funérarium
[Applaudissements]
c'est à eux de payer les trois premiers
jours et transport ils peuvent pas
garder le gars si la famille avait
demandé eux-mêmes par exemple pour
l'emmener à 100 km là c'est différent et
là selon vous c'est parce que les
familles ignorent
ça c'est clair il ignore tous la preuve
pour tout savoir bon courage merci au
revoir allez bonne journée merci
législation complexe et mal connue flou
sur les tarifs
urgences de la situation les raisons
sont donc nombreuses pour expliquer que
les familles en détresse se fassent
souvent abuser en payant trop
[Musique]
il existe pourtant des moyens de faire
baisser la facture grâce par exemple au
tarif du six furet un regroupement de 76
communes de la région parisienne
ce syndicat intercommunal a signé un
accord avec les PFG les pompes funèbres
générales qui s'engagent à offrir un
tarif négocié sur les obsèques pour les
habitants de ses 76 communes
un accord peu connu mais qui permet aux
familles d'économiser en moyenne près de
1300 euros
nous décidons de vérifier si toutes les
agences des PFG respectent ce contrat
dans notre scénario je prétexte la
maladie grave d'un proche pour demander
un devis à l'une d'entre elles
bonjour je viens vous voir en fait parce
que
je voulais prendre en charge en fait mon
grand-père et en face terminale cancer
et en fait je voulais un peu anticiper
les choses d'accord
j'aimerais bien déjà voir le devis avec
vous pour l'instant je vais prendre en
note d'accord donc son adresse pour
bénéficier de ce tarif il faut remplir
plusieurs conditions la principale est
que les prestations funéraires soient
effectuées uniquement dans les communes
du syndicat du transport du défunt
jusqu'à lanterne il faut également
choisir un type de cercueil particulier
le modèle Vauclair en pin ou le boken
je respecte donc scrupuleusement les
indications de la fiche si furet moi
chez je crois qu'on était quand même
parti sur quelque chose de simple
Vauclair il est
bien la taxe de convoi on la prend 30
minutes plus tard le devis en main
j'obtiens la somme de 4940 euros en
dehors des prestations obligatoires qui
ne rentrent pas dans l'engagement
tarifaire si furet j'obtiens une facture
de 2502 euros bien loin des 1269 euros
du prix négocié entre les communes et
les PSG est-ce une erreur du vendeur
connaît-il le tarif négocié avec les
collectivités locales je lui montre la
brochure si furet et lui demande des
explications et ça c'est mon cousin qui
m'a donné ça et il m'avait dit qu'on est
dans la même commune
il y a un tarif négocié chose comme ça
est-ce que c'est le cas
d'accord ok par contre là ça paraît
beaucoup moins élevé
RANTES
promis mensonge aucun tarif spécial n'a
été appliqué j'ai pourtant bien suivi
toutes les conditions pour en bénéficier
d'accord
silence embarrassé
le creusement
[Musique]
ce vendeur semble bien gêné pour
justifier cette écart de 1233 euros
jusqu'au bout il ne me proposera
d'ailleurs pas le bon tarif sifurer
[Musique]
nous avons reproduit ce scénario dans 6
autres établissements de la société en
région parisienne
certains jours ont le jeu on nous
proposant directement un prix correct
nous sommes délégataires de la ville
des 74 communes et qui se font inhumés
peuvent bénéficier de préparé dessus
avec les villes avec certaines villes de
92 qui font que lorsque vous choisissez
un certain type de cercueil vous avez le
droit de remise de 1200 d'accord
de communes d'accord
dans d'autres communes je ne tomberai
pas sur des vendeurs aussi honnêtes
bonjour monsieur et donc ça fait en tout
ça 1399 euros
ok bon ben merci beaucoup on prend ça on
ne me propose pas ici le bon tarif
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oui ça c'est mon père qui me l'avait
donné en disant regarde si furet par
rapport à des tarifs
d'accord alors après il y a autre chose
qui est-ce qu'on appelle le super si
furet d'accord je vais vous je vais vous
le montrer par contre
j'ai pas pu vous le faire dans le devis
contractuels
pourquoi le montant pourquoi il est
différent
et ça veut dire quoi
qui sont faits d'accord
choisissent de vous acheter un capot à
3000 euros
pas tout faire il y a des conditions il
y a un argument fallacieux ce commercial
nous explique ici qu'il n'applique pas
le tarif si furet pour clients qui
jugent suffisamment aisé ce qui est faux
tout le monde doit pouvoir en bénéficier
au final 4 de cette agence PFG
n'appliqueront pas le bon tarif
certaines en oubliant volontairement de
nous en parler d'autres en nous le
refusant la corps signé entre le
syndicat de communes et les PFG et donc
loin d'être respecté
nous avons pris rendez-vous avec la
directrice adjointe du siphuré pour lui
donner le résultat de notre testing
et en fait il y en a il y en a quatre
donc qui n'ont pas proposé ce tarifs et
quand leur expliquer aussi que après on
sort le petit brochure il y en a encore
certains qui disaient mais non vous
pouvez pas bénéficier de ce tarif il
suffit c'est quelque chose et il vous
donnait une raison il y en a un qui nous
a dit que c'était selon les ressources
des familles non c'est absolument pas du
tout alors c'est absolument pas selon
les ressources des familles et c'est
intéressant que vous me donniez vous
fassiez une copie de ce que vous avez
obtenu parce que voilà c'est le cas
typique si une famille alors prenons
l'exemple vous êtes une famille vous
nous remontez ces informations il est
absolument évident que nous nous allons
remonter sur le concessionnaire avec les
preuves à l'appui vous allez leur en
parler vous allez c'est tout à fait si
je vous dis donnez-moi donc copie de ce
que vous avez obtenu c'est parce que oui
la prochaine fois qu'on va aller voir on
va leur dire on va même leur faire un
courrier en disant preuve à l'appui
expliquer nous
nous donnerons pas les devis mais après
notre passage le si furet sait qu'il
devra faire de nombreux contrôles pour
s'assurer que l'accord avec les PFG soit
bien respecté
[Musique]
mon infiltration dans le milieu
funéraire touche à sa fin je dois une
fois encore me rendre dans un funérarium
pour y disposer le corps d'un défunt
l'occasion de rencontrer une dernière
fois des collègues toujours aussi peu
engageant sur l'avenir du métier
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
malgré un environnement toujours pesant
j'ai fini par m'habituer à une ambiance
plutôt bonne enfant car dans ce lieu ce
que l'on pratique outre les soins de
conservation c'est l'humour noir et ici
la mort on préfère toujours en rire
qui est mort dans sa voiture
dans sa voiture
pour ses professionnels il y a plus
grave que la mort c'est l'escroquerie
fait au vivant à la perte d'un proche le
thanatopracteur nous raconte une
histoire incroyable celle d'une dame qui
aurait payé 30 000 € pour l'enterrement
de son mari
[Musique]
et pense famille comment tu lui dis à la
plupart
[Applaudissements]
demi-tour par exemple elle dit non
funèbres très bien senti elle avait sa
mère qu'elle est sur le point de mourir
elle est décédée 15 jours après sa mère
son mari qui venait de décider dans les
circonstances aussi pas possible suite à
un cancer au domicile
vous pouvez pas vous balancer à Paris il
y a pas de place ce sera si et vous
pouvez pas le garder chez vous allez
bien
[Applaudissements]
et je suis retourné le lendemain le
lendemain pour pour voir l'état du du
corps pour voir s'il avait pas tourné le
machin c'est
impeccable et le professeur il dit mais
non vous pouvez le garder chez vous bah
oui pas de problème
c'est bon ils ont trouvé une place par
contre j'ai signé un chèque de 26000 €,
j'ai oublié le livret A ça me coûte
30000 €. mais parlez pas en ancien franc
et ben les pans d'ancien frère a parlé
en euros
elle était une personne était dans le
rouge
elle avait dit qu'elle avait été surpris
ouais je sais pas quoi on va sur les
mains la vidéo sur le livre et son mari
hé mais tu es trop contente donc on est
en cercueil le cercueil même un service
on a pu accéder à vos demandes par
contre ces 26000 € à elle tout ce
qu'elle voulait c'était quand c'était
comment
tu fais mais comme ça tu es habillé son
compte et peut-être à la gare
durant cette infiltration j'ai pu me
rendre compte qu'avec la loi du silence
qui règne dans le milieu la détresse des
familles qui ne veulent pas porter
plainte le peu de contrôle des autorités
et les petites combines pour gonfler les
prix le milieu du funéraire est loin
d'avoir chassé ses vieux démons
certains se battent pourtant dans la
profession pour leur respect des défunts
et des familles mais dans cet univers si
particulier le marché fait sa loi et le
tabou de la mort dans notre société
permet au secteur funéraire de prospérer
à l'abri des regards personne ne veut
voir la mort et son business en face